glowing lava and clouds of ash a volcano
erupts in Iceland on average every five
years the North Atlantic island nation
straddles the boundary between two
continental plates making it a
geological in its spot a huge bubble of
magma close to the Earth's surface eats
the groundwater and creates the famous
hot springs and geysers millions of
tourists come to see them every year all
right welcome to rave our holes headless
one of those easy Icelandic names now
for the first time
tourists can enter a lava tunnel in
southwestern Iceland that's over 5,000
years old we are basically walking in
the pathway of eruption you're basically
seeing how the eruption took place from
within how lava forms this amazing
natural wonder from within hot cream or
Christensen and his team laid out a safe
pathway through the lava tube for the
tours around 30 metres wide the tunnel
is the biggest on the island these
cavities formed when the outer surface
of a lava stream cools and hardens just
after an eruption wonderful wall here
with magnificent formations again glass
these formations give some impression of
how Iceland was formed this land is new
and you can touch like the basic of off
of Earth with volcanoes and everything
the geology is the single most
interesting thing about Iceland it's
everywhere around us everywhere we live
but here it's all concentrated into one
tiny place the numbers of foreign
visitors have increased fivefold since
al Fiats widely reported eruption in
2010 piling up the volcanic eruption in
2010 was our biggest marketing and PR
stunt in history basically initially we
thought I would diminish tourism in
Iceland but it did the axe act opposite
at the time Ragnar Seeger son got up
close and personal with the eruption and
infamous ash cloud and photographed it
he had to be quick
often it's impossible to predict with
certainty when an eruption is coming
until 15 minutes in advance
the photographer tried to get as close
as he could
I've been no exactly meets away from
glowing lava but it's moving very slowly
and of course I've been very scared I've
had to run really fast mostly because
I'm scared that's because things
happening but you know you're on first
and I'm you check Hrodna has been
photographing the volcanoes on his
island since he was 16 this crater is
only a few thousand years old he knows
very well why people are so fascinated
with the fire-belching mountains to go
up cochon photographing an eruption it's
kind of you know yes it's it's not
really rush the next best thing to
experiencing an eruption firsthand may
well be the new lava center in holes for
Europe which houses Europe's largest
volcano exhibition starting in mid-june
visitors here can journey through
Iceland's geological history when you
come into the room you will feel
definitely the heat emitting from the
mottled plume and then you will hear the
sounds of the magma traveling up
underneath Iceland and so the whole
experience will be based for using all
different senses you feel the heat you
hear the sound and then the eyes will
tell you how it all works the
subterranean magma flows are visualized
in 3d
visitors can use the globe to simulate
the motion of the tectonic plates
back in the lava tunnel Icelanders as
well as tourists are interested in the
islands geological phenomenon we are
very much aware that we live in a young
country and the way it is shaped and the
way it looks the way why it is different
from so many other countries is because
we have we're living on a hot spot so to
say fire and ice
beauty and danger Iceland is a land of
extremes just one reason why it's such a
fascinating destination for visitors